On the 7thof May, France will hold the most important presidential election in the history of the Fifth Republic.
After decades of elections fought between nearly identical center-left and center-right candidates,
the French have a choice between two political outsiders:
the centrist Emmanuel Macron and Marine Le Pen, the leader of the National Front.
Macron, who never held elected office before, claims to be neither on the political left nor right.
He promises deep economic reforms, liberalization,
supports the European Union,
and he's the only one of the four leading candidates to openly criticize Vladimir Putin and the Kremlin.
A Le Pen presidency would be very different.
At home, it would mean a return to heavy-handed industrial policy and protectionism.
Internationally, it would mean cozying up to the Kremlin,
which has supported Le Pen’s campaign both verbally and financially.
It could mean France’s exit from the EU and from NATO
– essentially the end of the postwar political order in Europe.
The choice facing French voters could not be starker.
What do you think about the French election?
Let us know in your comments,
and let us also know what other topics you'd like AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.